hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen on the second
episode of this series I watched
Jurassic Park for the first time because
I had only seen the third like multiple
times and I loved Jeff Goldblum in it
and everyone was like oh my gosh you
should totally watch the fly and that is
what I'm doing you guys I've heard that
it has awesome practical effects and
it's disgusting but I feel like it won't
be as disgusting as like current gory
like saw type movies which I just have
no interest in anyways I am pumped and I
am just so ready for Jeff so oh oh
Tanner has never seen okay why did you
tell me to watch that why did you tell
me to watch that why did you tell me to
watch that why did you tell me to watch
that why did you tell me to watch that
then there's that which I don't even
thank you I mean okay I did actually
enjoy the film
it's just mmm it was a lot guys it was
more than I was expecting
in so many ways so the movie starts off
and you see Jeff Goldblum in all of his
80s hair glory and he's hitting on who
you find out who is a journalist he's I
come over to my place I've got a
cappuccino machine she's like for you
so of course she goes home with him and
he takes her to this warehouse and at
this point I would regret falling for
the cappuccino pickup line because this
is where you die in this warehouse with
this awkward awkward 80s jet full bloom
that's how you die he was literally
playing the piano creepily and it's like
well now you've seen it you can't leave
and he's kidding obviously that's just
his loveable sense of humor so then he
shows her that he can teleport things
and he finds out that she's a journalism
that she's gonna write a story about it
and he doesn't want it out yet no no
that's why he shouldn't flirt with
pretty girls because they will ruin your
life then he convinces her to follow him
around for a while so she can get an
even better story and it can be released
when he wants and now they can fall in
love guys this is working out so well
then she goes back to her apartment to
find her boss slash apparent ex-lover in
her shower I would just not take kindly
to something like that obviously like
who would like hello hi Tamara
what are you doing in my shower Doug
what's better than Malcolm's isn't it
now go away I'm trying to be awkward and
ATZ pretty predictable why am I
surprised so then she tells her boss
ex-lover to leave and to give her her
key back and he's like nah I'll keep it
for old times sake I think you've
probably just had sex a couple times
like come calm down it's a car alarm can
you hear that I know my cat is yelling
at me so jeff goldblum attempts to
teleport a baboon and it does not work
out you guys it is a horrific bloody
mess also where did he get a baboon from
but apparently it sets the mood because
they totally do it in his warehouse
I like the nerdy but cute scientists
with the badass a sweet gentlest dynamic
they've got going on really realistic
then they you teleport at stake so this
is like the love story of the century
you guys come on this is only gonna go
into good places right right right so
through the experiment with the
teleported stakes they're like oh now we
can teleport the baboon so they can
another baboon cuz they have an
unlimited supply of baboons apparently
and they successfully teleport him or
her I don't know
so then she finds out that her creepy
boss ex-boyfriend is stealing the story
from her so she goes off to yell at him
about it and Jeff gets real jealous and
gets super drunk and decides to teleport
himself and it's the best scene in the
movie because he like triumphantly walks
out of the teleportation machine and
there's like mists behind him and the
monkey just like jumps in his arm he's
like making this as sexy as possible
that miss no I come here I need a monkey
in my arms okay so he saunters out like
this oh my god I miss pray it's okay you
don't want me for spray too you know
sorry okay so he saw herself he saunters
out like this I can't be with a cat my
arm okay I don't know how I did it guys
I am impressed welcome from and after
that it was not worth it
then Jeff gains all of this strength
which I wouldn't expect from a fly and
he wants her to teleport too because he
feels invincible and she's scared she
doesn't want to so she's like bro calm
down you're acting like a crazy person
I'll see you up these weird like insect
hairs coming out of your back so I'm
gonna go get that checked out by oh my
god
oh my god no okay stick here oh it's so
dumb
okay so he faces together that a Flyers
on the teleportation machine when he
teleported and now basically he's just
like a fly person like he's a garbage
fly human individual because I missed a
really good joke I was gonna say it's
too late it's too late
listen these bits there's no bits so
Jeff and what is her name
I can't not know her name and I'm also
just calling him Jeff
the flag is 18 1886 this was made in
1886 this was made in 1986
Seth Jeff said I remember now okay Geena
Davis you are just very pretty genius
Veronica
okay so Seth and Veronica are fighting
Seth and Veronica are fighting and Geoff
Seth realizes that he was wrong and he
was super rude to her and like kicked
her out so he calls her and has her come
in cuz he's getting kind of scared cuz
he's turning into pretty much like a
gooey rotten sack of potatoes is what he
looks like at this point it's not even
bad yet guys it's like not even bad yet
so she comes over and his ear falls off
and he throws up weird goo and it's just
like at this point I'm like oh yeah
someone help someone help this man
please so she's freaking out obviously
but she still loves him and it's really
sweet and like a sad terrible horrifying
way she goes to find help and she goes
to her ex-boyfriend boss
Veronica girl you need to put her money
in your life cuz you're got you got
Stefan you got the evil boss but just
just date a girl then you find out that
she's pregnant and I'm just like ah got
my stomach hurt by this point Seth Geoff
is in like orc territory of how he looks
and his teeth fall out and he figures
that to become a little less like a fly
he needs to teleport with a pure human
who volunteers then he finds out that
she's pregnant and she's gonna get an
abortion and she breaks through the
glass of this abortion clinic or this
doctor's office and like kidnaps her he
tastes her away and her xbox
ex-boyfriend boss comes to try to save
her and Seth Jeff fly man starts like
disintegrating parts of his body because
he doesn't want her to go with him so
he's like now missing an arm and and a
foot and it's just it's uh oh my god
it's the worst thing ever like this
guy's a fuckin asshole but I didn't want
him to like ah it's terrible oh and Jeff
Seth reveals that he wants to fuse
with her he's not like I thought he was
gonna fuse with the bad man at least but
he decides to fuse with the love of his
life
ah it's uncomfortable and so she like
tries to get away and she ends up
ripping his job and then his body parts
just start falling off just every one of
them just everything's just coming off
of this man and he's just a horrific fly
thing now so she's able to get free and
then Jeff Seth fly just just fuses with
the machine so he breaks out and he's
like half human sized fly half like
metal machinery and like he's crawling
and like wheezing and it's so God so
then she shoots him in the face and
that's the end that's worth pooping
I don't know guys it was gross it was
really gross it was impressively gross
and it's pretty much I like to say bad
it was interesting what do you think I
blew a fuse with me
I could be a real cat human like I've
always wanted no he doesn't want you oh
don't touch this I shouldn't have this
out that was stupid
so yeah that's the fly I guess cool love
story
awesome practical effects I think you
only need to watch it once to kind of
get the gist doesn't have much of a
rewatching movie got a thing here I'm
glad I watched it but I'm going to do
something a little tamer next time back
to the future let's know I've seen that
so by Tamra seeing your nightmares